i i think there's a practical uh reason
for a lot of this we've talked about
thucydides trap on the show quite a bit
are you familiar with the concept i'm
not no explain it whenever a rising
economic power is on the verge of
supplanting the dominant power
war breaks out okay i say whenever but
it's a tendency towards so uh historians
often say
the the last uh 16 examples of an
economic power supply
supplanting the the greater 12 instances
were led to war
so the idea is why is it that i don't
know joe biden is doing these deals and
flying to china and working these deals
with china china is expected to overtake
the united states very soon yeah it was
delayed because of kovid interesting
interesting about that it was delayed
because of kovan
and you mean the overtake the overtake
china i'm sorry actually it might have
been sped up i thought it would have
been sped up because china continued to
grow right i think it was sped up by it
but um
think about what this means
the u.s is eroding from within
you've got the january 6 committee for
instance actively trying so eric
swalwell was asked about this he was
asked about you know isn't what he do
isn't what he's doing causing more
division and he and he said something
that was like just inane like well we
have to do it or something like that
so yeah when they lie and escalate
justice millet russia gate ukraine gate
all of that stuff just lie lie lie lie
they are in flaming tensions when they
go after kids and divert them or say
subvert their their development and then
cause identity crises give them drugs
destroying the next generation is going
to [ __ ] the united states and
i have to wonder i'm not saying it's
intentional but it is fortuitous to uh
for those who fear thucydides trap
because the us is falling as fast as
china's rising
china may actually
take over the world uh the global
economy whether the u.s ever having an
opportunity to engage in war so if you
think about the council on foreign
relations i think it was they they have
on their website the liberal world order
and why it was created
anybody who's arguing for the creation
of a new world order in the wake of the
liberal world order and i don't mean the
new world order conspiracy i mean quite
the literal term a world order and a new
version of it
it would be beneficial to avoid a third
world war with china how would you do
that
destroying the economy the united states
and the upcoming generation to make to
make sure that they can't ever actually
engage in conflict there's a story i saw
recently where there's like a destroyer
that had like three captains rotate in
and out so quickly because they were
being fired and demoted the us military
can't recruit at all anymore so so
where is this coming from
no idea but i was this internal is this
external manipulation both maybe
that's the thing i find so weird it's
like this
social and cultural
domestic harry kiri right like
that
it's so odd to me i mean the uk is doing
the same things many western countries
are i think the u.s is kind of sadly
leading the charge in this and exporting
a lot of bad ideas but
there's really a lot of people have
noticed that in the past
i want to say seven to eight years
in particular
a lot of this is re the inversion has
really really accelerated and so much of
the stuff that we talk about and all of
the
so many of these issues are things that
it would
literally as recently as a decade ago it
would have seemed completely absurd
for them to even be debates or
conversations and
there's something real really really
weird going on i do want to point out
just a quick shout out to uh joe
spinella on the super chat who mentioned
shirley you haven't seen the tanks uh
protecting chinese banks because uh
chinese economy is like imploding true
true point fair point fair point uh i'm
not saying that uh china is coming out
unscathed it may be a global economic
collapse the whole system is just
imploding for whatever reason you saw
with the trans-pacific partnership in
2010 that was the first warning sign for
me barack obama signed on and it gave
there's this thing called the investor
state dispute settlement clause in the
trans-pacific partnership deal that
would have given malaysian oil
corporations the power to sue the united
states government and the taxpayers
would have to pay the bill if they
thought that americans were
discriminating against their oil
companies and didn't want to buy their
oil then they could sue us and it was
giving corporations insane power over
american citizens and obama was on it he
like he didn't know or he didn't care
and trump shut it trump shut it down
like the third day he was in office or
the second day it was in office um but
that they were trying to do that is very
overtly transferring power from the
citizen-american democracy republicanism
to corporatism yeah dude look at the
last two and a half years
like seriously i mean
how of all these countries
in a very coordinated fashion
i mean
it's one thing if one country goes nuts
but it's literally been
uk canada every country in western
europe pretty much except sweden usa
new zealand what what what was it that
world war one you had the the three
countries their cousins with each other
was like france who was it germany and
who else or something like that germany
austria i don't know i don't remember um
but it was like these three leaders were
going to war with each other were
cousins it's like they're all related to
each other that's just that i'm not
surprised by any of that
powerful
i think we're witnessing a controlled
demolition man
you think they're intentionally
destroying the economy and
dude everything that people are freaking
out with right now with the economy
supply chains inflation i'm not saying
you're wrong it's all completely
predictable and predicted by myself and
other so-called conspiracy theorists
like
well i got this stuff started it was
very predictable and and very obvious i
got evidence for you okay so uh i
shouldn't we'll call it circumstantial
evidence and we'll call it logic okay so
uh ukraine russia war right invasion of
ukraine
fertilizer from russia not getting
exported u.s is in trouble
ukraine and russia are neither are
exporting enough wheat they can't
produce any there's a war going on they
can't produce as much
global famine you've heard them talk
about it yes yeah okay then why in
europe are they telling farmers in
ireland and the netherlands to stop
farming in the uk and the uk why are
they telling these farmers these
countries stop farming right now control
demolition but uh hold on the same
people who are telling us that there is
going to be a global famine
are also telling their farmers to stop
farming
that's very strange isn't it i mean
they're saying famine is coming you
better stop farming arouse it's like
okay do you want people to like run out
of food yeah it's weird i mean the thing
is and and
it's impossible to not be a quote
unquote conspiracy theorist these days
after the past several years
if you are just interested in thinking
but they they've created this right if
people
who are in power or people in corporate
media and so on so-called public health
officials and the the experts which we
keep hearing about if they refuse to be
honest and they just continue to lie and
to gaslight and to shift gopros for
years and years and years on end like
every every single day they're just
lying to people then naturally you are
going to have people trying to work out
wait what is going on this narrative is
not making sense this is not logical
this is not rational it's not based in
science it's not based in economics
nothing
what what is going on it makes people
wonder can we stop it
i think people always ultimately have
the power we can resist the starvation
by growing local food well that's what
i'm getting to my question is if if we
are in a controlled demolition do you
think it's possible that people reverse
course stop this yes it's always
possible i i don't think this is the
first time being here in history by
voting for trump is what you're saying
mega
yeah i mean
look i i don't think that this is the
the first or even close to the worst
thing that humanity has faced on any
level um i think it's important to
always maintain a sense of gratitude and
perspective both historically and
geographically and i think there's a lot
of real stuff to be very very concerned
about but in terms of my optimism
i mean you look at history and man
there's
countless examples of very very dark
times where i'm sure people in certain
countries or across the just thought you
know what this is
this is a wrap this is the end like this
is a freaking a freaking nightmare and
people have always come out
on on the end of it thus thus far right
our species is still going there's more
of us than ever before
so i think one thing that people often
forget though is that history is not
finished
right it never is no history we're
living through the history of the future
right i'm sure if you go back to 1910s
and you talked to people in europe or in
america or whatever i'm pretty sure they
thought that they were very advanced and
they were past all the war and the chaos
and the famine and the genocide you know
we're cool we're advanced we're smart
we're moral we're decent people
and then boom world war one boom world
war ii right
that would not have been remotely
predictable well
what's happening now
they say that there's a overpopulation
climate change from too much pollution i
say okay they say we got to have
late-term abortions
then they got they say we also got to
give drugs to children that will
sterilize them and i'm like the end
result of that is just the left
conservatives aren't engaging in that
for the most part they'll be they'll be
brought down by it to a certain degree
but not completely and so i wonder about
this the end result
the strong survive
if there's an artificial flood or a
natural flood whatever you want to call
it some some emergency be it an economic
crisis an environmental crisis or a
cultural crisis in the end the strong
survive well it's the adaptable that
survive the strong may starve it's also
the people it's the people who show up
for it the future will go to those who
show up for it
so if i'm sitting here
saying to everybody who's watching this
show and you are as well like hey it
feels like there's a collapse happening
and it may be on purpose the the best
case uh the best evidence in my opinion
is that they're claiming a global famine
is coming while telling farmers to stop
farming that's indicative of they're
intentionally trying to starve reminds
me well so my point is if you hear that
you had two years advance notice
watching my show if you haven't for that
long to i don't know move out of the
cities
get some get get a small piece of land
where you can grow enough food for your
family or to buy emergency food and
start preparing for what may be coming
but i'll stress it again
when the powers that be screaming your
face for two years a food shortage is
coming
then you actively see them shooting a
cop shot a live bullet at farmers
because they want them to stop farming
it's like okay is that in the
netherlands in the netherlands like
they're willing to kill these farmers to
shut down their protest
yo they're telling you they are not
going to let you have food i think maybe
you should plan for that it may be like
a misdirected intention like i keep
thinking about mao's great leap forward
in the communist chinese revolution of
what was the 1960s and he moved all
these farmers off the farms and then
gave like all these people from the
cities he moved them out to the farms
like now you're in the farm but they
didn't know how to farm so a bunch of
people starved maybe it was intentional
i don't know stalin did the same yeah
you starve the the resistance and then
you have less resistance so
if they think there's an overpopulation
issue and they want a slower growth of
population
what would be a good way to do that dude
slower growth
depletion of it and the people
who are imposing this so-called
controlled demolition are certainly
going to survive the
famine
civil unrest whatever happens and then
the so-called like strong of you know
maybe people people watching this show
who do what the things that you just
listed are also going to survive it then
what happens maga people are the future
is that it i don't i don't think
anyone's overtly said they want less
people yeah people keep saying they want
that
true bill gates wrote an article about
it saying that there is way too many
poor people being born in africa and
that's what we got there's a lot of
slowdown there's a lot of anti-natalism
and it's it's not new anti-natalism has
been running for decades but
to your point
if
we're talk
your point about the strong surviving
when there's no food it's the people in
cities who suffer the people who live
out in the countryside like yo you drive
up the mountain everyone has chickens
like to them it's and people who are
listening to this who live in the
country know exactly what this is better
than i do because they've been doing it
their whole lives it's like you wake up
in the morning get eggs from the chicken
it's no big deal growing up in the city
you go to the supermarket to get your
bleached eggs now if there's a food
shortage the people who have their own
chickens don't have to worry about it
y'all you're going to be eating
cockroaches and bugs and crickets i got
like 30 40 chickens out there oh you'll
be oh they're oh they're pushing the
insects hard
the chickens are going to eat the
crickets and i'm going to eat that's the
way to go but chickens smell and they
they pollute the environment so not
everyone can have them unfortunately no
no chickens when they poop we so uh we
don't do it properly because we are
still living in this luxury what you do
is uh thomas massey man that guy's a
genius he has something called the klux
capacitor
it's a solar capacitor that charges up
and then releases a charge pulling a
chicken coop about an inch so all day
the chicken's coop moves
and the chickens poop in the grass and
he said the trail of grass behind the
chicken goop is lush and fertile oh wow
because the chickens are actively eating
the bugs in the grass and then
fertilizing the soil so it's a perfect
cycle
brilliant wow what you do in the
chicken's poop we've got these big
mounds because we did construction and
it's crazy how big and tall the the wild
shrubbery and grasses have grown on it
because it was just a huge pile of
chicken it is impressive
i looked up at it and saw for the first
time after like it was just a little
that was wild yeah well it was it was
two big mounds of chicken crap and it's
like i think what happens is the
nitrogen escapes from it and then it's
fertile and then the plants just go nuts
i'm with you zoobee i i think all you
guys actually kind of been touching on
this that that if they want a slower
population growth or less people one of
the two and they they want less carbon
in the atmosphere that they want we're
running out of food but they want the
farmers to stop farming it feels like
they want to starve a segment of the
population to propel and these people
that want it must be insulated from that
in some way i think it's because they
know that not the entire globe
can enjoy the
first world luxuries that a lot of us
enjoy
and
now they their version of preparing for
that prospect as the population grows is
to
by any means necessary deplete the
population and then hoard the resources
for themselves and no one i don't think
anyone knew stalin was trying to kill
his population until after it happened
or now until after it happened like you
don't know when it's coming otherwise
you've stopped it you prevent it exactly
yeah people understand that people also
are really bad at stopping things
they're good at running a river flows in
one direction well really again
i hate to keep referring back to the
past two and a half years we've just
lived through but i can't think of a
more blatant in your face example well
of people not stopping things when
there's a clear and simple opportunity
because tribal is i think people have a
natural tendency towards resistance we
have sports because they want to fight
against something it's also just fear
with the last two years there's such
an easy way to resist yeah and people
didn't do it
they still aren't doing it and ian makes
a good point though uh
when i was younger i used to complain
that people cared about sports more than
politics and i didn't understand why we
have these stories about you know bush
and the invasion iraq and then you get
obama and i'm like i wish people cared
more about this than say like the
packers or whatever and now i'm
understanding exactly why that's a why
it was good that we had sports
people don't care or want to understand
they want tribal conflict and so while
they're saying i choose because no one
forces you forces you to do this they
say
i'd rather watch the baseball game and
argue with my friends about who's better
at baseball and then i say well i care a
whole lot about the conflict so i'm
going to pay attention to that it
actually works out really well that the
people who aren't smart enough or don't
want to engage in worldly affairs choose
not to so they're not voting for evil
people or being susceptible to
demagogues but once tribal once
politics became pop culture now you have
people being sucked into the demagoguery
of the democrats or you know they argue
donald trump but it's the democrats that
are funding trump supported candidates
while claiming they're the apocalypse so
this is what the democrats have done
their call i saw this montage it was
horrifying
where all of the cable news outlets are
talking about the january 6 hearings as
a season of shows with a season finale
they have made it entertainment to
escalate political conflict to me like
you were saying zubi it sounds like
they're doing it on purpose to cause
political conflict i wrote for newsweek
when they when raskin included me in his
evidence that this is the goal to drive
a wedge to create escalation thanks for
checking out this clip from timcast irl
come hang out live monday through friday
at 8pm eastern time super chat we'll
even answer some of your questions if
you want to check out the after hours
censored show go to timcast.com and
become a member we put those up monday
through thursday at 11 pm they're very
funny not very family friendly we'll
love to see you there thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time
you